ですから いいことをするとかなり力があるという法則なんですね
例えば五力にまとめたら
サッダ・ヴィリヤ・サティ・サマーディ・パンニャーという信・精進・念・定・慧
それが五力でいて その力五つもないとサマーディさえも禅定さえも生まれません
だから禅定を作る人 悟る人のところでは
もう心はすごいエネルギーが充満しているんですね
ものすごい強力なエネルギーが充満していないと
もうサマーディも悟りも現れないんです
すごいエネルギーが必要なんですね
で 物質的に考えると 例えば我々にはエネルギーがないんだから
地球の引力に引っ張られて
もう地球から全くもう出られなくなっているんですね
体は重い そこで我々には無力状態に
無力じゃいいですか 無重力状態にいたければ
全く重力ない体はもうゼロ
重量は 状態にいたければどうすればいいんですかね
我々はロケットの中にでも乗ってね
すごいエネルギーを持って脱出しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから あまりにもエネルギーが充満して固まったんだから
ロケットはこの重力ある圏から飛び出すことはできるんですね
それ飛んだところでどうなること全然力がない状態になるんですね
だから ないかあるか その時はもう関係ないんです
無重力状態だから そういうふうに物理的なことを考えればわかりやすいと思いますね
だから この信・精進・念・定・慧という五つの力がすっごく固まったところで
心は解脱に飛び出しちゃう
解脱っていうのは何もない状態なんですけども
煩悩も重さも何もない状態
普通ないいことをするためには
この貪と瞋だけで十分です
そこで悪いことをする人にとっては
無貪無瞋の力しか持ってない
智慧も何もないんです
それが力のココナッツ
それからこの支配者の四つが出てくるんですね
こちらはあの主とね 書いてますけどね
四主はね 欲主・精進の主・心の主と観の主であると
パーリ語ではこのパーリ語の言葉を覚えた方がいいんです
チャンダ・ヴィリヤ・チッタ・ヴィマンサ
これどういうことかというと
やっぱりいろんなこの窓口やら働きがあっても
誰かが主任の身性がいてまとめなくちゃいけないんですね
区役所なんて例えたら
まあ区役所のそのその窓口のいる人々がまるっきり独立して自分勝手に仕事をするというわけにはいきませんね
みんな区役所のもう様々な窓口で仕事をしている人々は
もうある誰かからまたコントロールされてまとめられているんですね
それで区役所という働きが結局成り立つんですね
まあ区役所は都庁の例えは良かったかもしれませんだけどね
ものすごい用心だからね
やっぱり誰かまとめなくちゃいけないんですね
だから区役所やら都庁の例えで考えちゃうと
やっぱりまあ東京の知事ですか
誰がですかとかね というふうに感じられますけど
やっぱりそれでもね 彼もまた誰かにもう管理せねばならないしね
こういう例えでわかるように
やっぱり法律ですね とにかく
法律というものがありまして
まあそこでまあ総理大臣からみんなちゃんと管理されているんですね
いつでも まあ国の場合は自分の上に誰かがいるんですね
そこでその上の人を見たら
その人の上にまた誰かがいる
その上の人の上にまた誰かがいる
それで国の総理大臣まで
やっぱりその人の上にまた誰かがいる
誰ですかというと やっぱり法律なんですね
それは犯せないんですね
ですから そういうふうに心の中にはいろんな窓口
いろんな働きはあるかもしれません
エネルギーもあるかもしれませんけど
まとめ役は 誰がするかというと
これつなんですね 人でできているんです
ただ一人だけじゃないんです
その人が番目はチャンダ
こちらのチャンダはまあ欲とね
訳してますけど 欲っていうのはこの厳密に漢字で読むんじゃなくて
一般的な日本語で読めなくちゃ間違うんですね
漢字で読むと意志と欲ですからね
そうじゃなくて 一般的な日本語で欲ですね
パーリ語にもそういう意味なんです
いわゆる何か行動したいという
じゃあ行動しましょうではないかと
頑張らんといけませんというふうな
この意欲みたいなもの
それは悪い方向にもいい方向にもどちらでも働きますけど
これ誰と絡み合うかということなんですね
例えば無惨無喜と絡み合ったら
もう悪い方向に行ってしまっちゃうし
斬と喜と絡み合ったらいい方向へ行ってしまうし
この欲なければ人は行動しないんですね
わかってはいるんだけど
それで終わっちゃうんですね
やる気が出てこないんですね
ですから まあやる気みたいなね
欲 そこを出てこないといけない
そういうのは育てなくちゃいけないんですね
強引にでも やっぱりやる気っていうものをやるぞと
作らないと いくら心の先進性が揃ってあっても
何も役にも立たないんです
番目はヴィリヤ 番目は精進ですね
だからこのいろんな心性の中で
精進がまたまとめ役の働きもします
精進というのは窓口にもなるし
そう それから力にもなるし
それ それからまたまとめ役もする
次にチッタ 心ですね 心そのもの
それはあのチッタはこの窓口にもなります
それはウィコンと出てきたもの
それも心なんですね 認識する心ですから
そこでチッタアディパティの心は強く持つこと
まあアビダンマではね
持つと言ったっても それ生まれつき決まってるんだということもありますからね
やっぱり三因縁 三因ですか
三因生まれでないと もう心は弱いんだと
あるいは二因の強で生まれないと
もう心はもともと弱いんだと
だからまあ悟りの方向はいけないというふうにも考え方あります
でも三因か二因かということは個人は知りませんしね
ですから とにかく弱い心でも心の流れの法則から見ると強くなるはずなんですね
今は弱いんだけど ほんのちょっと強くする
ただ ほんのちょっとの強い心はほんのちょっとまた強くすると
そういうことであの強くすることはできます
チャンダチッタ チャンダ・ヴィリヤ・チッタ・ヴィマンサ
で 番目はヴィマンサですね
それはこちらで観と書いてますけど
この観察ですね これはサティという場合は念であってね
まあその時その時で働きではないんでしょうと思いますけど
まあ同じ可能性もありますけど
本当はヴィマンサでは智慧なんです
心祖としてはね で お釈迦様はこういうこのこのよくおっしゃってるこのアディパティ４つね
あの種の４つを随分育てたんだと
誰よりも だからもう最初に道を開くことはできたんですから
並ならぬ努力ないと この道の闇からね
光を作ることできないんですね
だから同じ闇の中でぐるぐる回るように
我の心はプロセスされているし
だからとにかくすごい力を持って修行して悟りを開いたし
ですから それからの人々にはそれほどこの四種の種を必要ないかもしれません
お釈迦様ほど必要じゃないんです
まあただ適当なぐらいあればうまくいくんだということなんですね
初めて道を発見するためには大変なエネルギーが必要でしたということで
ですから この修行に自分がどれほど力を絞っているか
どれぐらいやる気があるかとかね
それによってこの人の理解と
それから瞑想 結果として得られる徳が変わっちゃうんです
で 瞑想によってすごいこの物事を見られる鋭い観察能力つく人もいるし
物事を説明できる能力つく人もいるし
ただ何の能力もついてない人もいるし
瞑想は進んでいるかもしれません
悟りまでいくかもしれませんだけど
別にもう何の能力も特別能力ですか
ついてない人もいるんですね
それはこの四つのインディパーダという
インディパーダ アディパティ
インディパーダとも言うんですね
尽力とも言うんですけどね
こちらは種と書いてますけど
また尽力という言葉でも同じを扱ってるんです
尽力の人と足の足 いわゆる尽力に足さなくちゃ
足りなければいけない力と
だから同じグループの人々がヴィパッサナー瞑想したっても
まあ同じぐらいに成長
成長しても そのその個人差として
あのプラスアルファでつく能力っていうのはそれぞれ違うんですね
だからまあきりがなくもう喋りまくってる人がいると
で それは精神というのが落ち着いてないんだからなんですね
そこでその人にとってはまあプラスアルファで落ち着いてきて
まあ言葉足らずなくなったとかね
まだ全く無言の人がいるんだと
喋れないんだと ということは頭の中は整理していない
物事を明確に見られていない
喋るためには そういう人は瞑想したところで物事を見られるようになったと
それで頭が綺麗に整理されているんだから
よく喋れるようになったと
今まで喋らなかったんだけど
今は何のことなく人の前で喋れるんだとかね
いろいろ能力が出てくる
本を読んだっても 回 回読まなきゃ理解できない人もいて
その人はもしかすると瞑想したところで
まあ一回読んだだけでわかったと
内容は覚えているんだというふうなこともあるしね
だから個人にはどんな
この これプラスアルファの能力なんですけどね
まあ付加価値としてついてくるもので
で そういう能力をどこまでつくかということは決まらないんですね
本人がこのつつの種をね
どれぐらいあるかっていうことで
例えばヴィマンサという勘というのはね
鋭い人にとってはものすごい幅広く物事を知られるようになります
特にこの言葉の制限と人間言葉を使う時はどのように間違っているかと
この概念の問題とかね
いわゆる世の中の哲学は全部一発で解明できるんです
説明もできる いいところも悪いことも説明してあげることができるようになるんです
世の中のことを勉強しなくてもいいんです
聞いたらもうその人でわかってるんです
これはこういうことで
あなたはこういうことを言ってるのではないかと
そちらにはこういういいところと
そういう欠点も落とし穴もありますよということまでわかるようになります
それには勘という種がかなり働かないと良くない
出てこない 例えば精神的にいろいろ能力ついたんだと
いわゆる超能力みたいに
で そういう場合はやっぱりチッタ
心自体が種としてかなり働かないと出てこないんです
番目ですね チッタアディパティ
心の種 欲の種と精進の種っていうのはまあまあほとんど似ていて
だから欲の種と精進の種なんか働いた人々っていうのは
やっぱりあのもしヴィパッサナー瞑想でもいくらか進んだところで
すごい元気になると活発的になる
すごい行動 素早く行動する人間になってしまう
いろんなことを考えて考えて
どうしようか これで困った
あれで困ったとかね そういうことはなく
じゃあこうすればいいんだから
じゃあやりましょうと
すぐこの行動的に性格変わっちゃうんです
いわゆる明るくなるっていうことなんで
すごい明るく活発的な人間になってしまう
なんか超能力っぽいものがつくのは心
種が働いていると 常の力ほどじゃないんだけど
その人がいるだけで だから瞑想していた人だからいるだけで雰囲気が綺麗になると
みんな落ち着くと 顔見ただけで
だからなんとなくその人の心の中になんかすごい違う波動が働いてるんじゃないかなと見えてくるんですね
そこでその人と喋っても喋れなくても
まあみんなすごいいい気持ちになるんですね
そういう風に働きなんですね
だからこれつも揃ったらもう抜群ですけどね
でお釈迦様にはこのつも揃っていたんですね
だから知らないものは何もない
お釈迦様には対話できない人っていうのは一人もいない
それでいただけでも まあみんなじーんと落ち着いてきます
それでいつでもお釈迦様はやっぱり行動的で
行動しない人まで まあもう切り捨てる
もう出て行けと 今やらなくちゃいけないと思ったら
すぐその場で瞬時に行動する
ものすごいあの 三ヶ月間歩かなくちゃいけないところで
あの辺に人がいるんだけど
あの人はまあいくらか瞑想できそうだなと思って
まあいつかいつかそこら辺に行ったところで説法してみようかなと
そういう気持ちじゃないんです
あ あの人はまあよくできたできてる人やと
じゃあ行かなきゃと すぐその場出て行っちゃう
目的のところに行くまで 三ヶ月かかる
それはあまり気にしない
一人の人を治すために行くんです
そういう風な性格でしたからね
普通の人はね たった一人のためにね
三ヶ月間かけてなんで行かなくちゃいけないんだと
会場に行ったら あれは毎日何千人も人が来るんじゃないかと
そういう風にケチな計算するんですね
逆にお釈迦様 この人々はいつでも私に会ったことあるんだからね
頑張れるものだったら
もうそっこーに悟ってるんだと
だからそうじゃなくて
あの人に喋ったならば
あの人一回で悟れるんだと
じゃあ行きますと すぐもう
すぐ自分の勝ちどころももで出かける
明日大勢の人が来る予定ですよと
そんなもう気にしない
だから行動的っていう全部揃っていたんです
まあそろそろその辺終わると思いますけど
大体このまあ全部一回はもう説明して終わってるんです
ですからもう簡単に簡単に言っちゃった方がいいかもしれません
本当はこのもう阿鼻達磨としては言うべきところは終わってるんで
まだ残っているのは因果法則だけ
因果法則と悟りの瞑想のヴィパッサナーの段階ですね
次にアーハラですか 食
受用想ですね アーハラっていうのはやっぱり付け加えるエネルギーなんですね
アーハラというのは食べ物ですから
食だから外から入れなくちゃこの機械は働かないんですね
ですから外から入れる
入れたものは使ったら消えてしまう
それは燃料ですね それで当然ながら生命は仏教では次元的だからね
物質的な機械と精神的な機能という次元的だから
次元構造だから 食も次元構造でなければいけないんですね
だからただご飯だけではダメなんですね
物質だから一番目は えーと一番目はカバリー
カバリーカーロ アーハロー
カバリーっていうのは
こっちは暖色と書いてますね
もう団地木と読みますけど
暖色でしょうか 団地木ですよね
いわゆるこの物質 水やらジュースやら飲み物やらご飯やらパンやら
そういう風に体に体に入れる物質的なエネルギーは番目
番目から番目までは心を動かしているエネルギーなんですね
だから心を動かすためには
その四つ三つのエネルギーをあげなくちゃいけないんです
それですごいその輪廻の法則もそれ説明できるんですね
一番目はパッサ触れること
だからこちら生命体がいるならば
この生命体はこの外界
内外を認識するでしょう
この外界 内外は触れなきゃ体に
で 私は例えばラジオを持っていると
電波がアンテナに触れなきゃ
機能しないんですね そういう風にこの何とかの形で触れる必要はあります
例えば体だったら物は物はそのものを触れなきゃわからないんですね
体で認識する場合は 時計を体で見ないで認識したければ
時計を体で触るということでないとわからないんですね
目で触れる場合は 時計はそのままであれば構いません
目では遠くあっても触れる
音の場合も やはり音の始まるところ
資源ですか そこは耳に入らなくてもいいんです
太鼓の音を聞きたいんだから
太鼓は耳の穴の中にいる必要はないので
それはもう遠くあればで耳に触れるんですね
でも味の場合はやっぱり遠くあってもダメなんですね
舌に触れなくちゃいけないんですね
香りの場合は また鼻の中に入れる必要はないんですね
で 距離があった方が香りが嗅げるんですね
そういうふうに体の場合も
やっぱり外の世界は触れる関係が違います
ただ触れなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで内観というのは心の回転なんです
そこで心の中にもいろんなアイデアやら
いろんなものを心にいきなり触れちゃうんですね
だからパッと何か考え方が浮んじゃうんですね
何かぶつかったという感じが心の中でも起こるんですね
だから即というのはそういうふうなことで
次にファスワーハロー
マノサンチェータナ 次には
チェータナですね 意志ですね
チェータナというのは意志だから
こちらはこのイノシシと書いてますけど
これ何のかわからないんですね
まあただの意志ですね
ですから何か知りたいという
知りたい やりたいとか
なんとかってエネルギーは心の中に生まれるんですね
その心の中に生まれるチェータナ
こういうをしたいという意志自体で心が回転して
この知りたいものは知ってしまうんですね
やはり心は回転するんですね
4番目はヴィンヤーナ
心そのものなんですね
心そのものが触になっちゃうんです
これどういうことかというと
だから触れると認識が生まれる
それでわかります やりたい
知りたいという気持ちがあると
もうわかる 分かってしまう
で 心回転する それはわかります
それで心があるならば心が回転するという機能なんです
ということは 今の心が死ぬと
その理由で次の心が生まれるんです
だから なんで今私に心があるかというと
ちょっと先に心があったんだからなんです
ちょっと先に心がなかったならば
今は心がないんです なんでこの感情に心がないかというと
その先にも心がなかったんだからなんです
それものすごい単純な法則なんです
心が一つ死ぬ瞬間で 死ぬと同時に新しい心が生まれる
だから新しい心が生まれるための原因になったのは一つ死んだことなんですね
だから この物質の世界では例えるのは難しいんですけどね
まあ例えば米が死ぬことでご飯が生まれるでしょうに
同じものだから ちょっと理解しにくいんだけどね
ご飯でもあって米でもあるということにはならないんですね
風船を爆発しちゃうと音が出てくるんで
だから風船が死ぬことで音が生まれると
風船そのまま大事にしちゃうと大きな音が出てこないんですね
だから花火にしても 爆発するということは必ず必要であって
そうすると花火が生まれると
そういうふうな この時間はの間がない
風船が爆発する同時に大きな音も出ると
だから大きな音があるということは
もう風船がないということなんです
花火があったということは
もう花火がもう爆発して
もう元の状態はもうないということなんです
で そんなような流れの法則で
一つの心が消えたということは
次の心が現れたということ
だから 消えるエネルギーが新しいエネルギーが作るんですね
電気もそういう法則で流れてるんです
電子一つ出ていたら そこに新しい電子が入っちゃうんですね
そこである方向に電気が流れると言うんですね
電気流れる場合は このなんていう電圧というね
ことあって 高いところから低いところに流れるというふうにはなってますけどね
その電圧の考え方で言ってちゃったら
遠く遠い場所に電圧があるようになりますけど
やっぱり電圧はずっと一つ一つのエレクトロン電子の中にまだあるんですね
だから一つは外に出て行っちゃうと
もう一つはそこに入ってくる
だから出ていかなきゃ新しい電気電子が入りませんね
例えばこの蛍光灯なんか消したければ
我々はスイッチをオフにするでしょうね
何をするかというと 流れないようにする
そこでスイッチのところまで電気があるんですけど
そこに次には流れませんね
だからこの一番先っぽに電子があるんです
あるんだけど それ消えません
そのまま止まってるというかね
スイッチオンにしたらつなげるでしょうね
そこでこちらの電子はそちらに行くんですね
死んじゃうということで仮定すると
こちらにあった電子が他のところに行ってしまった
そこで新しい電気がそこに来るんですね
それで電気の流れが生まれて
蛍光灯は光ったりはします
光る場合も同じなんですね
光の光子が出ていかなきゃ
次の光子が出てこないんですね
それで光っていうものは存在しちゃうんです
ですから この物の流れ
電波の流れ エネルギーの流れ
波の流れって いつでもそんなもんなんですね
一つ消えることで次のことは生まれる
だから波の場合も 水の中に波が仮定すると一つの波が下に行くということは
次のところで波が高いと
M ですか 上に行くっていうこと
上に波として上に上がったっていうことは
ずっとそのままいられるわけいきません
だからまた下がるだけじゃなく下がってしまう
しかし その次のところでまた新しい波が生まれるんですね
だからこちらは下がるということは
次の瞬間で上がるということで
だから心もそういう波で一つ死ぬということは
次の心生まれるという波が作っちゃうんですね
そこで心は切れないですね
心の波が切れなくなっちゃう
流れが切れないんですね
この切らないであるんだから
私たちはあるという錯覚はします
電気があると言ったって
もうこれ本当におかしいことで
一個一個電子が別々なものだからね
どれほどの新しい電子が生まれてきて流れているかってことはわかったもんじゃないしね
我々は同じ電子 電気だとすぐ勘違いしてしまう
それで心の場合は心の栄養になるのは前の心が死ぬことは次の心の栄養になって新しい心を生み出すんですね
それで切れなくなっちゃうんですね
で それは輪廻の法則になっているんです
だから二重構造で生命は説明しているし
一構造だったら体は生命であると言ったらもう体が止まったら腐っていくことは見えているんですね
体は機械だけだから ですから
そちら心の構造もエネルギーの中でも働いているんだから
だから壊れたのは体なんですね
心は壊れるということはあり得ないんです
一つ消えると次の心が生まれますから
そこで人がなんで輪廻転生するかといえば
死ぬんだからなんです
別にそれに複雑な論理があるわけじゃないんです
新しい心はなぜ生まれるかというと
前の心死んだ理由で新しい心は生まれるんですね
僕はものすごい瞬時にすごい速さで死んで生まれて死んで生まれてきますから
我々この機械の故障とは関係なくなっちゃうんですね
人間が機械の故障は死だと思ってます
で 仏教ではそれだったら死はないんですね
ずっと流れているんだから
死はないとも言えるし
いつでも死んでるんじゃないかと
体という機械にしたっても
いつでも細胞死んでるんじゃないんですか？いつでも新しい材料を入れて新しい体を作っているのではないか
いつでも持っているのは新しい体でしょうと
だから常に生と死の流れでないと体は維持できないし
同時に心も生と死の流れでないと維持できない
だから体と心というのは二重構造であることは明確だから
ですから いとも簡単に心の流れがもうある
ある物体に依存して動いていても
その物体に依存しなくなってもすぐ流れていっちゃうんです
そのは栄養ですね 受想とも言うし
色とも言うし  [咳]そこでまたこの法として分けなくちゃいけないんだから
二十二では あの 法のことを書いて
この この場合は いわゆるコンと言ったって窓口と言ったってもいいし
預流果になる時の 時の智慧は
あの 道を知るという言葉で
預流果の心の 預流道の心だから
預流道の心にある智慧
道の 道を知りたいと知だと
道を知る智慧だからね
そこで知ったというのは
まあ知ってしまったと
もう終わったと 反抗する場合は
阿羅漢果になった心の智慧に相応だと
間 預流果 一来道 一来果
不還道 不還果の間は このアンニャタービンルエですね
なんていいますか 境界内容知るコンと言われると
だから境界内と言ってるでしょうね
コンとは知る智慧なんですけども
そこでこの名根っていうのは
物質の命を注ぐことと
心の命注ぐことの二つに分けてあって
二つだよと言ってるんです
で 五識の中にはセンスは得られず
六識の中にはもろもろの力は得られず
それから無因の中には動詞は得られないと
で まあ心の世界を言ってるんです
同じく自心印の中にある一教勢は道根基とならない
因三因の即行の中にも
それぞれ発生に従って種が一つだけ得られると
まあ一旦それであの 一つのセットは終わります
雑のセットは終わります
次にこの また瞑想に ヴィパッサナー瞑想に必要なこと
また同じことなんですけども
同じことをまた禅だけの方にまとめてまた言うんです
説明するべきか 四時までですか？四時半までですか？四時半
四時半まで 次にあるのは
この二百十九ページのボディパクヒヤ
ボディっていうのは悟り
パクヒヤっていうのは
まあ悟りに関係ある 悟りの方向に向いてる
あるいは悟りに必要な法ということで
菩提分の節ですね だから
そのこれから説明する禅
信処 位 状況 全部一つ一つ悟りという条件を作るために必要な部分ですね
部品ですね 全部揃えなくちゃいけない
それはだいたい三十七あるんだと
三十七ですけど 繰り返し言葉は全部出てくるんですね
一番最初に出てくるのは四つの念
念中の四つ それはサティパッターナですね
あの心住心法とよく言っているこの四つの念ですね
で これボディパクヒヤってなぜ菩提分と言うんですかというと
例えば あの体を感知していることは誰にでもあります
私に手があるんだ 足があるんだとかね
やっぱり知らなきゃ生きていられませんだからね
だから常に体に対する念というのは人間にはあるんです
人間にでも動物にでもあることはあるんです
それで生きてるんだから
自分に体あることは知らない生命はいないでしょうに
まあ寝ている時はどうか分かりませんだけど
起きている間は体という実感はいつでもあります
あるんだけど あれは菩提分にはならないんです
ただ 生き続くために必要な最低限に自分の体を認識しているだけなんです
我々は歩くときは足の感覚を知ってます
ね あの 歩く瞑想しなくても
知ってますけど それは
あの 無事歩けるぐらいで
最低限にそこに集中しているだけ
それで歩く